hi there I'm Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big think
podcast since 2008 big think has been
bringing you big ideas in small
concentrated doses from some of the most
creative thinkers and doers around on
think again we take ourselves out of our
comfort zone surprising my guests and me
your host with unexpected conversation
starters from our interview archives
ideas that we didn't necessarily come
here prepared to discuss I'm very very
happy to be here today with William
Shatner V William Shatner he created the
role of captain james t kirk on the
original Star Trek and won two Emmys and
a Golden Globe for his portrayal of
denny crane on the practice and boston
legal he's also written nearly 30
best-selling books of fiction and
nonfiction and released two awesome
albums of music with the artist Ben
Folds and others including Henry Rollins
who's been on this show his newest book
zero-g co-authored with Jeff Rubin is a
science fiction terrorism thriller set
in the year 2050 it begins with an
unnaturally powerful tsunami that
destroys most of the coast of Japan and
follows FBI field agent Samuels Lord as
he attempts to unravel the mystery
welcome to pink again William thank you
that was a long introduction but very
very well done good thank you very much
I want to talk about your book but
before we do that as I am a long time
Shakespeare fan and I know you started
out in Shakespeare I wanted to come out
of left field and ask you whether you
have a favorite character play speech
etc of Shakespeare any of any favorite
thing of Shakespeare I wondered if we
could start there a favorite Shakespeare
character character play speech moment
um and you know i guess i have to point
at henry the fifth in which i
understudied Christopher Plummer who was
playing Henry fifth at Stratford many
many years ago and in repertory
especially this repertory at Stratford
you open a play and then the next
morning after you've opened you start
was on new play and then you do that for
four weeks and then open that and maybe
a third and a fourth so that the
understudy rehearsals would be delayed
until you finished opening new plays and
about the third or fourth day I was
asked to go on stage as the understudy
because Kris was ill for a moment and
they asked me to go on and I had never
not only had I never rehearsed it I
never said the words out loud but I had
been drilling myself for some reason and
I speculated about this in my one-man
show why did I drill those words so so
emphatically because nobody ever goes on
for an under say right no I've never
been in an understudy relationship where
somebody went on for me or I went on for
somebody else rye cept in this one
instance in which I never spoken the
words out loud and then I went on stage
in front of 2,500 people and and critics
and all that and how did it feel was it
terrifying how did it had no I was on a
wave I I don't recall being terrified i
recall i looked at pictures of Laird
Hamilton coming down a way that you know
70-foot ways okay and I've got to think
that he had the same feeling it so I did
this this thing pursuing you you're
riding and and you can't lose your
confidence because the moment you doubt
your it's over so so that's how that's
how it is for you you feel that you
mustn't you must keep self-doubt
completely at bay because I've often
thought that you know for me anyway you
can feel the self-doubt and then say oh
well you know there that is and still do
your thing you know and just having
acknowledged that's that's good if you
can say oh well there's set out there's
fear and there is dread and there oh
look at that there's a stereo coming my
back right and then you know somehow
deal with it and press on for me in life
denial is perfect just denied the Panda
I the experience denial oh that hasn't
happened is not going to happen I don't
even want to think about it and I'll die
before I I experienced that and
eventually it all goes away anyway so
I'm half Jewish and so for all semi or
fully Jewish but yeah yeah go ahead
Jason you should be in denial about well
I was going to say that Woody Allen gave
us all permission to sort of recognize
the terror and the anxiety and simply to
move forward and and turn it into
something I don't know if not sexy at
least acceptable in this case turn it
into a man a career yeah so you've had
an amazingly varied career you're best
known to the general public probably for
the Star Trek films but you've been
doing a million things and and you've
been writing for years and years now how
did writing enter the picture for you
where you know at what point did you
decide to start taking writing seriously
if that's the right way to put it well I
the written word is where everything
begins and ends I've always known that
so I've always written in one man or
another I love poetry i love the usage
of words in fact when I was just
starting out I wrote some television
half hour plays which the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation the called the
CBC in Canada which was the equivalent
of say NBC here bought and I cast one of
those shows a girl and eventually
married her she became the mother of my
children so I've been writing a long
time but the perhaps more measured and
important works started when there was a
strike by some unions while I was making
a film and there was nothing I could do
I had to sit around and wait for the
strike to be over so I started writing I
gave myself the premise of a policeman
in space okay I had done a police series
so I begat ten books and it became 10
books a year a year series and a movie
so I've noticed you know I saw you know
looking through your work and by the way
I really love those those albums that
you did with Ben Folds they're they're
really cool that
was called has been it was I really look
at that that was it's wonderful and I i
I'm just noticing that in both the
writing and in the music you're
collaborating and you seem to enjoy
collaborating I mean acting is the
collaborative art as well do you find
that you prefer to create with other
people as opposed to in solitude so
science fiction is strange form you're
imagining a plot and people but it's
also littered with scientific
possibilities either imaginative
possibilities or possibilities that
exist in the laboratory that may come
into existence years from now right and
you have to be acquainted with all that
and it's a very esoteric acquaintance
ship to know science intimately to be
able to write about it no science
intimately Jeff Rovin is this wonderful
writer who who has that knowledge so
between the two of us me working on the
more emotional aspects in the plot and
him working on the scientific aspects
we've created a lovely novel filled with
scientific possibilities both that take
the plot along or that are added like
little diamonds that that you'll read
and may even smile at new political
unions that couldn't possibly be right
in our year but 50 years might very well
come to be yeah that sort of thing is
great phone what are so in the new book
in zero-g I mean I think I gave a enough
of an overview of the plot I don't want
to give too much away it's definitely a
fun and interesting thriller set in
20-25 what are some of your favorite
moments or ideas in the book anything
you'd want to kind of highlight for
people who haven't read it well we have
a character there we took from the
present-day publicity about people who
feel they've been born in the wrong body
so we can name that character at zilla
and at Zilla instead of going for an
operation changing his or her sex is
able to do it by will that's
totally an imaginative concept taken
from the ongoing controversies that are
in our day and age but someday in the
future there'll be a medical implant
whereby by an act of will you can change
your sex yeah I found that really
fascinating first of all Ed's illas
parents I guess genetically altered her
either at birth or pre-birth and so that
raises some interesting ethical issues
you know like about we are going to come
to a point no doubt in the near future
when parents actually may have some
control well I think with enough
instrumentation that can look into that
aspect of an unborn baby since we're on
the verge and in fact not on the verge
we're genetically altering but we're on
the verge of genetically altering almost
anything easily why wouldn't it be
possible to go inside even just a
concept right and alter the genetic
structure of the unborn child it is
happening when they see diseases that
are abnormal why couldn't you do almost
anything well let me ask you this where
you know if you were in a position to
sort of start all over and have kids and
you had sort of unlimited genetic
alteration power what would you take
advantage of it or what would the limits
be for you personally well you see what
you're addressing there is a real moral
problem right how much do you alter
genetically that goes for food as well
by the way right GMOs are apparently
healthy they're allowing us to feed
seven billion people that shouldn't be
on earth in the first place by being
able to feed seven and maybe 10 to 11
billion people in the very near future
we like lemmings have destroyed our
environment right and we're only going
to destroy it further so we've
genetically altered crops to avoid
disease so the limitation is not only on
what food is but how many people we can
procreate and Chinese tried to do it by
limiting it to one
person but that didn't work because now
their culture didn't want girls they
wanted boys and saw a whole human aspect
to something that was going to be really
good a scientific breakthrough that
offered humanity the hope of feeding
everybody and nothing no no starvation
morphs into more people and more
pollution and the end of the world right
the end of the world is nigh because of
the number of people on earth and how do
you reduce the number of people on earth
without getting into mass murder or
altering the baby in vitro and not being
able to have any children okay the
morality that that this brings up is the
springboard for so many science fiction
novels and that's what we're that's what
I'm doing indeed well in your in zero-g
there is at least a science station on
the moon there are you know fairly
complex space station so I mean that you
know at least Elon Musk with his you
know SpaceX Mars MIT Mars mission
mission seems to think that that may be
one viable solution as well you know
where there is no way that human beings
can colonize any place else other than
then earth because the the time it takes
to reach an earth-like planet that has
the proximity to its star and many of
the values here which includes this thin
skin of atmosphere and the temperature
range and the oxygen the oxygen
proportion came about by evolution when
chlorophyll started I mean it you go
back one thing brings on another right
so that by evolving here on earth we
human beings have arrived at a reptilian
brain and our complex forehead that
evolved over millions of years how the
heck you can't live underground on Mars
even if you could you can't that's we
belong in sunlight and that sunlight is
thousands of years in the future even if
you could go at a rocket ship near the
speed of light which you can't
it's going to take thousands of years we
have forgotten we've got things on the
books laws on the books understandings
with other nations on the books 50 years
ago that we've forgotten what they were
well you know that's right we made an
agreement 50 years ago we forgotten in
50 years what that agreement was or what
we were supposed to do or imagine going
a thousand years on a voyage and
somebody saying five hundred years from
now why are we here what do we where are
we going on right they are though Jesus
I've forgotten what let's look back in
the library and dusting off 500 years oh
that's right we're on our way to sent
out but why are we going there maybe if
they let's turn around maybe if they can
figure out wormhole travel and get us to
some exoplanets in you know 10 minutes
then Roy will be in that situation but
exactly and and that's theoretically
possible as well maybe yeah I mean
Stephen Hawking seems to think so but so
okay I think that brings us to the
second part of the show where we watch
these short surprise interview clips I
don't know what they are I've not seen
them so I want to you know we're going
to have a genuinely spontaneous
conversation the first one which is by
Ryan Holliday who's a entrepreneur and
author so but what magician we're is
this is thought provoking is that the
ideas ideally it is thought provoking
and if it's not then it's my job to
provoke will make it though exactly okay
so we'll both watch and and then
afterward we'll talk
there's a wonderful Bill Walsh quote
about it you go he says you know ego is
when self-confidence becomes arrogance
self-assertive pneus becomes reckless
abandon and so forth you sent you saying
it's it sort of past the point of any
reasonable utility right confidence is
great arrogance is not great or Cyril
Connolly sent ego like cancer is sort of
an over assertion of cells and that's
sort of what i see ego is it's it's
great to believe in yourself the problem
is when your belief in yourself is not
based on anything real and so that's the
enemy of trying to do basically anything
that requires interacting with other
people right if you're a creative and
you're not able to take feedback because
your ego is either so strong where we're
not able to take feedback because you
don't care what anyone thinks your works
not going to get any better if you don't
care about your audience you don't
understand who they are and what's going
on in their life because you lack
empathy which is another symptom of you
go your work is going to suffer you
can't work with other people because
you're you have to be this you're
selfish you have to be the center of
attention of all times you're not going
to have a team around you so it
basically makes anything that we're
trying to do harder than it already is
I guess I wanted to I wanted to get at
you know the old phrase fake it till you
make it right and I don't know whether
that advice rings true to you but the
idea that at a certain point in your
career like when you're starting out and
you're doing a bunch of new things and
you're stretching yourself outside of
your comfort zone as you kind of said
earlier you have to be sort of in denial
pushed down any doubt and just kind of
in a way bluster forward perhaps but
he's he's saying that that's kind of a
dangerous state of affairs I mean that
if I'm if I'm reading that right well
let me first of all correct what not
correct but add to what i said about
denial i was half joking about denial
but indeed as a performer and i was
talking specifically about being on
stage and stage fright and all those the
unknowns or a I'm a pilot for example
and i remember when i soloed in a Cessna
and i was making a turn by myself for
the first time the shadow of the
windshield crossed my face and I looked
up with a great start thinking something
was coming at me was just the shadow of
the windshield I was so afraid of what I
was doing I was up in the air at 1,500
feet I didn't know what I was doing now
if you panic god knows what will happen
so you need like a test pilot to control
that panic and like an athlete in a big
game use it so that you you extend your
your faculties to to their limit right
some people can do it by combining the
use of those nerves some people say I'm
not going to even face those nerves I'm
going to focus on what it is I have to
do and suppress anything else both work
I think but if you talk about ego then
what this gentleman is describing ego
and and trying to do something that
somebody else has never done or that
you've never done he starts off with ego
and the need for the self confidence on
the feeling that I can do it but then he
paints a picture of somebody who was so
egotistical that he doesn't listen to
anybody else like a watch your ego
because you're about to step off
precipice right so you might say oh well
that's where the precipice is you can
still be filled with the ego I've got
the I've got the kite in my hands and
I'm going to step off the precipice just
point me to where the precipice is if
you don't mind and I've got the ego that
I will sail this kite in space but just
help me with the help me get to the
precipice you can have ego and
overwhelming overweening ray go what
what what kind of a mind would get in a
spaceship and go to Mars who would do
that right except somebody who thought I
don't care if I live or die I'm going to
make this adventure the reality of the
Columbus sailing a ship over the edge of
the earth the reality is that he knew
the earth was curved or he heard the
earth was curved but there were many of
his crew who thought the earth was flat
you sail long enough you fall over the
edge they were on the edge of a
precipice right they thought or
certainly Columbus thought screwed I'm
going forward and I'm taking the risk of
all these other people's lives because I
think we're gonna find the spices and
that I think that's what I wanted to get
at you know what he said was that you
know you shouldn't you sort of shouldn't
overestimate your ability but when you
are going into the unknown you don't
know what's going to happen but nation
yeah Jason yeah I don't even need a
grand adventure a lot of relationship
what do you think right go out I'm gonna
go out I'm gonna ask that girl for a
date right right if you're shy if your
basic nature is shine you feel unworthy
and she's so pretty and she's so you you
think that that's above and you suppress
all that and you venture out onto this
Flat Earth of the edge of a precipice
you're going to ask for a date yeah you
have to suppress all the feelings of
inferiority and and and think I'm okay
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna be home and
and not only that but the fact that
people that anybody gets married knowing
as little as anybody else knows about
anybody else when at the point at which
they get married no matter how well they
know each other they don't they don't
know any other way
that's exactly right they and I'm one of
your fuel thorities who can attest to
that very fact you don't know anybody
that you marry until you've been married
a length of time yeah even then strange
aspects reveal them so I mean to go into
that kind of adventure which people do
over and over again certainly requires
if not ego at least some kind of
suspension of disbelief you know well
see now you're you're in the area of
suspension of disbelief that you're okay
you can do this this is worthwhile and
your mother and father say son Jason hey
don't marry that girl right and you say
dad I'm doing it right and your dad says
all right it's your life okay don't come
to me and some time later you ring your
dad and say dad you were right right me
and maybe what maybe he'll be right
maybe he won't but you know maybe he'll
be out because he's got his own
prejudices and he doesn't know this girl
any more than you do so you can see how
complex the picture is without painting
a psychopath yeah yeah who says don't
talk to me don't brother I know
everything and I'm and we we've heard
some of those Psychopaths I'd don't talk
to me I'll fix it I alone can fix I
believe i was listening to just such a
psychopath two nights ago there you are
so and that that I I don't admire but
there are people whose core knowledge
right of something is so profound that
they say look you don't know what I'm
talking about whether it's higher maths
or astrophysics or or this relationship
you don't know what I know right and I
therefore I'm going ahead with my ego I
think I'm right and you're wrong those
people who have been right and you were
wrong were the people who people who
explored all those new ventures mhm
they're the creative productive human
beings who've lived individually
isolated individually over the
generations one or two or ten people in
a generation right
made these steps into the unknown that
advised against it by everybody will you
hear these kind of things like about for
example Stanley Kubrick right who is
undeniably one of the great directors
right but allegedly he was just you know
completely he map out his entire
production didn't want to hear from
anybody actors were essentially tools in
his hands yeah and and and you you know
you can stand aside and you can look at
that and say ok that's bad uh or he
might have learned but it's not yeah
it's but it's not bad yeah and it's a
perfect exam right a director of a film
has a vision right and his vision maybe
I thought uh you know those shoes you
need to tie you need to tie the laces on
the shoes that's my vision right the
wardrobe person as well you know they're
made so that shoe laces are untied I
don't care my vision right is tie the
shoe laces as incidental as that that's
the vision why shouldn't that be sure
why should the wardrobe mistress have a
vision that supersede the director yeah
and I think it's probably true also and
you've worked with many directors that
people have just different styles some
are more authoritarian and and always in
charge of everything and some are
probably like I know Jason more it has
to do it has to do with the vision yeah
a director may have a vision and every
aspect like why would a painter say to
you um okay yeah go in and dabs of some
color on my painting it's okay sure he's
got the vision right is painting the
whole picture that's what that kind of
director would do other directors say
well it doesn't matter tie the she
listen don't tell the show I'm cutting
above it and that's their vision anyway
right that's right um yeah so you it's
hard to argue what is ego and was a
psychopathic right right yeah what is
ego in the healthy sense of sort of
knowing what you're doing and knowing
why is there anything healthy about ego
right well yeah I mean
seems so I mean well yeah because most
people you know what did the first
person say look we've just come out of
the tree let's head north right and the
evolution of mankind began some
individuals said that's I you know I'm
tired of sleeping on the tree here let's
lie on the ground it seems much more
comfortable yeah but you'll get eaten I
think I'll be alert enough to hear the
tiger come yeah it's called leadership
basic it's called leadership that's
exactly right and how can you lead with
a group of people it's complex my friend
and this guy telling us that the ego
then leads you into psychiatry as I
think interesting incorrect okay let's
leave it at that assessment and let's
move on since our time is a little
limited to the next surprised video and
that's nikhil Goyal he's an education
expert all right
the statistics show that bullying is a
major major problem in most American
schools and what they find is that in
school schools have a number of
different qualities and one of them is
the anti-democratic governing structure
if you look in most American high
schools for example they are gargantuan
mammoth institutions they have thousands
upon thousands of kids walking through
the hallways every day and what what
happens as a result of this and this is
not necessarily the fault of teachers or
even just the people in that school
building when you have such a large
student body and you don't have you have
large class sizes there's not enough
time for students and teachers to have
really strong authentic and genuine
relationships and students basically
what happens is they don't have any
relationships with their fellow peers
and and students at a really rich an
authentic level and so when students
feel that they have no power or no
agency and their school experiences what
often happens is something called clicks
arise so if students feel that they have
to real power and get control within
themselves and within their ranks and so
clicks are one of the major phenomenons
in American schools where they create
basically power structures within the
student body themselves
I actually want to start in a sort of
oblique way and then come to the bigger
ideas here I wanted to start with like
you know let us take a trip in the
Wayback Machine to Canada when you were
a kid were there bullies in your school
were you a bully were you bullied was
there was that a thing in your that you
dealt with uh well you want you want to
bring this specifically to me after you
why not just go not in bullying I want
to start well I mean I just find that
it's sometimes helpful to go from the
particular to the general and it a
little more colorful I'm happy to us oh
yeah well when I went to grade school
and maybe even as far as high school I
was brought up in Montreal Canada okay
and I'm Jewish and being Jewish in the
milieu that I was in was unusual and so
I was attacked a lot as a kid for being
Jewish and I had fights every day it was
more than one guy at a time and crowds
of kids gathered around yelling fight
fight fight and I'd be the one in the
fight trying to handle one if not two
and sometimes three kids my size my age
and I I had fights all the time and one
bully I remember in particular who was
there were places where Cole was dumped
into the furnaces so they were raised
like two feet above the ground and so
they provided a place maybe four foot
square that was like a crowning place so
somebody would stand on this and be the
bully and then they do try and get you
off that was part of the game to see you
could stand on the highest place the
longest part of a bullying campaign but
that's my experience but being bullied
okay I was bullied all the time no I
mean just looking back do you feel i
mean not that anyone would wish that on
their child but did you become like
tough as a result of that or was that
well that's that's an interesting aspect
you know wish on your child is an
interesting phrase you wish only the
best for your child kindness eagerness
ambition softness to lifeless pink
lots of food layin Oh soft bed good for
private you wish they would have that
but what does that make right what kind
of a child does that make when you talk
about bullying it seems to me you need
to look at life around you you look at
other animals living in concert with
each other look at a wolf pack every
social animal that i can think of
chimpanzees as close to human beings
apes all the great apes in concert when
they live in concert there's one or two
alpha males or in elephants maybe it's a
matriarchal and the alpha female and
they alone at least in the wolves they
alone breed and their children are alpha
children and they're handled even the
insects bees think of it most maybe all
aspects of life living together there's
a dominant individual but at the same
time don't we have to say that like
humans while we are like other species
we're differentiated by the fact that we
have a prefrontal cortex we organize
into society's we have the option to
make decisions we organized into
societies in which there's a leader
elect them or their appointed or they
assume there's I know there are leaders
and there are followers do the leaders
achieve leadership by bullying that what
I'm saying is that we we don't it
doesn't necessarily we don't have to
organize things as kill or be killed
that we are different from other animals
in that for example we you and I are not
going out every day and like machete
anao there are humans that are doing
that but no but you how did you get this
podcast well not by machete anyone had
me well and not literally but did you
push somebody aside who might have had a
podcast I me not you not not literally
but well not literally and but somebody
could have had a job but you got it
right right right good point good point
um I love making a good point no it's
right it's it's good so you know going
back to what he would
saying in terms of power structures and
how they create bullying I mean
regardless of whether we think that this
is a natural state well no not
regardless that's the point okay the
point is it seems to be a natural
evolvement evolution in in a in a group
that if the group has to do something
other than to sit around and go into the
ocean and and toast marshmallows by the
campfire then but then somebody's
brought the marshmallows and somebody's
made the sticks so in every group that
needs to go to do something go someplace
there's always a leader let's go there
now let's go okay let's go seven steps
in that direction see what happens yeah
I guess where i guess where i wanna and
you know and we're not debating i mean i
guess where i but where I did where yall
differ well where I differ is maybe we
are where I differ is just using the
word differ hey where's my differ
William we are not I oh it's not a
zero-sum game like we're not nobody's
keeping score right I that's not i don't
i'm not trying to win the the podcast by
anywhere okay Irene so no what I'm
saying is like leadership and bullying
aren't necessarily the same thing are
they oh I mean now leadership and
bullying are not the same thing so where
do you go where do you work how do you
mitigate all those things so let me tell
you what what I think about that I think
we need to teach from birth on empathy
we need to teach the ability from one
human being to the other to place
yourself in that person's running shoes
baby shoes spikes riding shoes we need
to everybody to say listen to what this
person is saying and crying out for help
to be listened to look at my experience
here look at what you've trod on my toes
and that hurt let me explain to you this
hurt you've crushed my toes and that
hurts and I don't want to hurt
you and I'm Norman maybe I'm not
incapable of hurting you but listen to
how I'm hurting and maybe you don't do
it again and you teach empathy to
children because empathy may not be
natural sympathy maybe but empathy to
live in somebody else's mind for a
moment and understand completely what
that other person is feeling i think is
taught and you need to teach that and as
a result of that may be aspects of
bullying would dissipate yeah maybe
there could be more empathetic
leadership for example a more empathetic
leadership which will hopefully get
after this upcoming election fingers
crossed we'll see William Shatner it has
been great talking to you and I think
we'll leave it there because we are
almost out of time and zero g 0 g is the
new book it is really really interesting
and exciting and it's set in the in
20-25 20 2015 really and but about 25
budget so did I can do not know it's
alright it's just a few years difference
I'm being empathetic I'm being an
empathetic leader right here it don't
worry about right I understand you made
a mistake in 20-25 but it's really 2050
but not to worry about it I'm with you
all right and let's go toast
marshmallows and go toes one virus
thanks so much for a pleasure talking to
you Jason pleasure talking to you
and that wraps another episode of think
again I know you are busy I know you
have lots of good things to do with your
time still if you liked our show or love
our show and especially if you're
listening regularly and you haven't had
a chance to do so yet I would really
appreciate it if you could rate or
review us on iTunes or your favorite
podcast getting location thank you we
are back next week with novelist Jody
picou whose new book is a big departure
for her it deals with racism in
contemporary America see you then